you know the day-to-day if it's our
grandmothers if it's our children
um if it's our brothers and sisters you
know just help them
find ways to you know to feel good to
connect with each other
um and to create healthy habits
[Music]
thank you for joining me on this show
really great to have you here thanks for
having me it's so so great to have you
you know you going to boston university
then to nyu stern
moving on to all the all these great
companies teva pfizer
as financial analyst but then going on
to brain technology
and now finding yourself at joy ventures
and it must be
the best name that i can think of for
any group or any organization i would
love to be a part of a group called joy
ventures one day so you already have my
resume on the way
uh give me a little background about
what you're doing
because it just sounds fascinating and
take me through your journey a little
bit
sure so today what i'm doing is running
a really cool as you said
not only by name but really cool overall
organization
a very unique one called joy ventures so
what we do
is we focus on the wellness space
consumer products for well-being
and we do so with a very unique model
which is
to build support and fund companies so
we don't only
invest in existing startups but we also
work with innovators and entrepreneurs
to actually build startups from scratch
and we even go as deep as academia
to actually identify promising research
and technology development
uh to work with those folks as well to
try to
turn those ideas and technologies into
products and companies
so walk me wait wait wait hold on i need
you to walk me through that process a
little bit because i get this idea of
investing in existing companies
young entrepreneurs come up to you and
they say we have this great idea we need
some support so that we can grow and
scale and validate our product
but you're saying you have a different
model it rings a bell to someone
of what my friends at teammate are doing
what is this idea of
what is it yeah so
there are some parallels to teammates so
basically
this is a model that is actually
becoming quite common
um in terms of the startup building so
it has many names today in the market
like startup studio venture builder
um yeah those are kind of probably the
most popular uh terms for what we do
and basically what it means is um
sometimes even if you don't even have an
idea yet
or you know you're really just excited
about the space
but perhaps you're an experienced
entrepreneur and you're looking for your
next um
challenge um you know you can come to us
or to this kind of organization
um specifically if you're interested in
our domain you come to joy of course
and actually we've just launched this
week um our new entrepreneur in
residence program
eirs are common in in various species um
here what we're doing is
basically working with a couple of biars
who just joined this week
they're experienced founders they've had
exits
they've got the methodology down but now
they're going to deep dive into our
space
and try to either work with our ideas
that we've actually
we've built this idea bank through
various innovation programs that we've
run with our
community so they can either take some
of the ideas off of our shelves or they
can just deep dive
um you know into market research be
inspired by sort of
you know their understanding of you know
the market needs
and then come up with their own idea and
then actually spend six to eight months
developing that idea
into a you know mock-up prototype um
putting together a business plan all
with our you know support as needed
and then come to us at the end of their
eir program
wow uh period and basically pitch their
um their idea to us so that hopefully by
the end of that period
we would be ready to invest and start a
company with them
wow okay so that sounds incredible so it
sounds like you're really tackling this
the the part of the the validation of
the product and the validation of the
market
through your experience and i mean
having people that have gone through the
journey and have
have done this sort of validation and
this research i think it's you know it's
it's it's a
priceless but then you know the the real
struggle is then finding the people
who are willing to take on this
incredible journey for seven to nine
years right and and you know marry
and be passionate about the product and
marry the company
sort of so so i mean is that do you find
that to be
you know at a similar caliber to the
research
how do you go about even evaluating
people who are coming in you know
really fresh or or you're looking to
match people to a certain idea from this
idea bank
yeah it's definitely not easy uh it took
us
actually um i think close to six months
uh recruiting this first cohort of uh
eirs
we are really looking for a mix you know
of
um the right experience obviously um you
know a cultural fit
because they're gonna be really part of
the joy team right
um for the next six to eight months so
we really wanted to make sure that there
was good chemistry and that we felt that
you know
there was also some basic uh you know
you know connection to our domain we
want people to really be passionate
about
um consumer products to be passionate
about um like human centered uh
you know design and um you know this
ultimately when we build companies or
support companies
um we want to have actually a really
strong sort of multidisciplinary
team that obviously has to have a really
strong
you know entrepreneur founder um at the
helm
but you also obviously want to have you
know strong tech
uh and and strong product especially
since we're in the consumer product
space we really want people have a good
understanding of you know market
consumer um you know trends and so on so
one of the things that you mentioned
right before this was also this idea of
you know wellness products and and
products that
you know are that that ultimately bring
good to the world and
and and you know promote wellness
promote well-being what does that mean
to you give me some you know tangible
examples what does that mean
you know thinking about products that
are you know for well-being or for good
yes so it's funny um and this is maybe a
good place to
to sort of talk about my journey because
um
you know i grew up um i was born in
israel i grew up
in boston my parents relocated uh to
boston for work my dad wasn't high tech
my mom is a neuroscientist
and actually um that's where my first uh
my first
exposure was to the brain and fascinate
this fascinating organ
right that controls you know our lives
and uh so from a very young age this was
you know part of the kitchen talk
and it was always very inspiring and i
had really great role models and even to
this day when i'm almost 50 years old i
still talk about
you know what grade models my parents
are very often in my interests
and so when i went on to uh to
study even though i didn't go into life
sciences or
or technology um in my education i chose
economics right
in business what i found myself though
um really connecting
to was the life science industry and so
um very quickly you know i found myself
you know going into the pharmaceutical
industry and there i was exposed to
many of the you know central nervous
system illnesses both tethra
and pfizer are companies that are very
strong in neuroscience you know
developing products for you know things
like alzheimer's parkinson's uh just
so it's interesting miri because what
you're saying here is you know you went
into these companies as a financial
analyst right you took your economics
and you
you you took your economics degree and
you brought that into those companies
yet what you're describing here you're
not describing your analytical work
you're describing the passion that
you've
accumulated over the years for the life
sciences
what i found about myself very quickly
was that um you know there are two
things that really drive me to an
organization into a position um
one is the the subject matter so it
doesn't matter if um you know if i'm
crunching numbers or if um you know
if i'm doing any kind of uh marketing or
management or any kind of role
i really need to connect with the
organization's mission um and the second
thing is obviously the people
as you know as cliche as that is um
connecting with the people that i'm
gonna
be working with um and what made me you
know stay at any organization for such a
long time was really just because i've
worked
really um smart inspiring you know
uh um good people high integrity people
and uh so what i found myself you know
um
doing was really working in the
pharmaceutical industry learning about
not only how to be a good financial
manager uh but also about you know about
brain illness and about
um about how to how a product uh you
know how a drug
um basically is developed and goes to
market
um and how it's actually then uh
[Music]
long life cycle in the case of um you
know innovative pharmaceuticals
and then i also uh experienced a short
time
in in the non-pharma healthcare uh
industry i i worked for a physician
practice management organization also a
very large publicly traded company
um svp finance but then um when we moved
back to israel
actually um ten years ago after uh
living in new york for 12 years with my
husband three kids were born there
we i found that i really still was very
passionate about the life science
industry but that i wanted
to um really kind of make a shift from
uh from big corporate uh to kind of
sensing the you know the sort of the
more
early stage sort of start-up nation uh
environment
uh which is you know such a really
amazing and unique uh
um environment here in tel aviv here in
israel
very different from the very different
from the positions that you've held up
until now
very very different about the company
pfizer
yeah extremely different and as a matter
of fact when i first came back
you know when i was networking and you
know no one knew me here really because
i hadn't grown up here i didn't go to
the army here i didn't start my career
here i spent 12 years in new york
even though i had very you know um very
admirable positions you know it's you
know in israel obviously people want to
see your um
your back people want to know you and um
they want also to see a relevant
track record so when when i went started
talking to vcs and startups about
joining they said well
you've never done this before so you
know um
doesn't matter that you have you know 15
to 20 years experience you've never
you've never raised money you've never
done you know
um you've never commercialized that or
you know brought a product to market
um so that was that was rough um but
really what happened
this is the word that i always use is
serendipity it's one of my favorite
words in english which i don't think you
have
we have in hebrew um is you know it was
just a
luck and timing and um i had learned i
just found out about
i read in the media actually about our
former president um
perez uh announcing that um he's gonna
launch this
um initiative to drive brain research
and technology in israel to turn israel
into a leading you know brain technology
hub
and that vision really resonated with me
because obviously
neuroscience was like such a big passion
for me um all those years
uh as well as you know it kind of the
whole
concept and the whole vision um was
really about
um you know about innovation about
startups and about you know
bringing kind of this this kind of the
brain tech startup ecosystem to the next
level or even creating an ecosystem
which really didn't exist i mean the
different
parts of um the small israeli community
of
you know brain researchers uh
entrepreneurs
clinicians you know whether it's a
neurologist psychiatrist neurosurgeons
no one was really talking to each other
um and there weren't really investors in
israel looking at
the space so or at least you know they
were only looking at it
very initially and what ibt is real
brain technologies which i ended up
establishing
um with rafikidran and a very famous
serial entrepreneur in israel
and which i led for for almost seven
years um what we ended up doing was
actually
bringing that ecosystem together
breaking down all those silos
um and creating programs for that
community including a startup
accelerator for branching companies and
international brain tech conference
um funding for brain researchers etc um
to really push that
you know push that um sector forward
and really establish israel as a um as a
strong you know international brand
technology hub and we really brought
um lots of important fake global
stakeholders to israel for that
conversation
um and so that was a really amazing
journey for me because i really
it kind of in a way it forced me to kind
of you know leave the big corporate
sort of greenhouse you know it was it
was an entrepreneurial venture
even though it was a not-for-profit but
it was really my first startup
um it allowed me to keep my passion um
in life science and neuroscience
and innovation but also brought out in
the you know sort of the more broader
leadership which i you know before was
kind of limited
to my financial hat now i was you know
um
able to really be kind of the evangelist
for this organization you know to
to be the you know the person that
brings people together
um and to really lead all the strategic
aspects and you know put together this
whole operation
which i'm really proud of it's really um
really to this day i think it's one of
the most
really special experiences that i've had
professionally
wow you know in my career so and that
brings me at the end to to joy because
i have way i have so many questions now
i don't even know where to start hold on
i i we're gonna have to have an extra
long episode this time
i have to know so first of all brain
technology you know it's a black box to
so many people like myself
that you know it it feels like it's such
a complicated field that i have to go
and study biology and neuroscience and
if i even want to begin to understand
what's happening so so dumb it down for
me a little bit
what can i be excited about brain
technology
today and you know if we're
extrapolating a little bit further ahead
five ten years in the future
what are some of the most exciting
advances in your mind as to brain
technology and perhaps how it literally
can shape
you know our lives i'm constantly
inspired by by nathan and trotter from
from tel aviv university with neurosteer
that's about the scope of i know and and
the way the work he does
it's a good place to start that's and
and still i don't understand anything
from what he does that's why
so i need you to dumb it down for me
talk to me a little bit about where
we're headed
so i think brain technology can be
defined uh you know
can be defined and interpreted in a
variety of ways
um so you know some people think of
brain technology um
as only like the sort of the type of
technology that directly interacts with
your brain like brain computer interface
you know any um type of technologies
that either measure
uh your brain waves or your your brain
activity in some way
or actually influence your brain
activity right like brain stimulation
whether it's a deep brain invasive
stimulation or non-invasive brain
stimulation so
that's just one piece but the way i like
to look at
think of brain technology is really any
kind of technology
any kind of innovation that can really
um measure or affect our
our brain state or our brain health so
um if you think of technology more
broadly i mean in a way it can also be
pharmaceuticals right that can you know
that can treat brain illness
um but it can also be some kind of app
right that can
um somehow through the various sensors
that we have in our phones or
wearables we can you know somehow
monitor our stress level or monitor you
know monitor our anxiety level
our mood depression levels so you know
there's a startup
um there are startups out there that are
now you know
tracking behavioral uh or or or um
mental well-being right companies that
have raised hundreds of millions of
dollars like mindstrong and others that
are
you know that are um helping people who
are living with you know with mental
illness
better manage their illness helping
their uh caregivers and loved ones you
know um
be a part of that you know caregiving uh
and and make sure that they you know
that that they get just in time uh sort
of alerts
if there's something you know wrong
going on so it doesn't always
necessarily have to be a cure
it doesn't have to be the ultimate you
know solution for parkinson's
but if we're doing anything to like
improve people's
um well-being or health and that kind of
brings me to
you know sort of the joy part of brain
tech which i mean we don't only do brain
tech at joy but
we're looking at if most of the years i
was involved in
you know companies or organizations that
were focused very much on brain illness
and
kind of trying to find ways to help
people who have various types of brain
disorders um what we really focus on at
joy
is kind of the other side which is
the majority of people around the world
um you know
luckily uh although these days during
copen and i'll talk about that in a
minute it's a different story but you
know
um maybe only one in four
uh you know are suffering from uh it's
still a huge number from
you know mental illness and there are
other statistics related obviously to
neurodegenerative disorders but the
majority of people at any given moment
um are just you know living there are
generally healthy
from a from a brain perspective let's
say or from a well-being perspective
they may have other issues right we have
a lot of big issues in the world
regarding chronic disease and
and you know heart and obesity and so on
but
um but most people are just dealing with
modern life
and that means you know stress and that
means poor sleep and that means you know
um anxiety and sometimes just feeling
down and all those things are not
you know you know diagnosed conditions
they're not
described as you know some kind of
illness that you necessarily have to go
to
get a prescription for to start some
kind of medical treatment but
we're learning more and more about
ourselves that they really affect the
way
they really affect our quality of life
so if you know for the last 20 years
people have been really focused on
understanding that they need to take
care of their bodies through nutrition
and physical you know
and exercise people are becoming more
aware in recent years that okay i also
have to take care of my of this part of
my
my body right i need to make sure that
i'm relaxed
that i'm finding ways to kind of like
reduce stress and
and find ways to just improve my daily
life because
the stress isn't going anywhere in most
cases i mean most
most people can't control um you know
what some people have a choice but a lot
of people are going to be in high stress
jobs they're going to have not only
stress at home
i mean at work they're going to have
stress at home right the young
generation is balancing i mean the
highest you know level of stress today
is experienced by
um by the young generations who are
balancing work and life and and you know
they're working very intensively but the
good news is that that young generation
is actually much more aware
they already are embracing technology
they're already
you know the ones that are trying
meditation and yoga and all those things
but they're trying to see if they can
find those solutions through their
phones or through any kind of gadgets or
devices
um because they're very tech savvy and
digitally you know native you know
you're mentioning this and it's funny
because you know i so i i do enjoy
taking part in a lot of projects and
various opportunities and and
oftentimes that goes instead of sleep
and my girlfriend was very angry with me
because
she's rightfully saying that you know
sleep is one of the most important
things and i'm not even aware of how
it's affecting
my mind or my body so i got this ring
from a with inspiration from that yeah
it's an aura ring now she doesn't really
allow me to wear it it's awesome we love
aura
we love aura you know i've been wearing
it for about two weeks we had one in the
office
but someone lost it so now we have to
order a new one
so now you know we're fighting over it
everyone was using it
yeah amazing but now you know i have to
you know every morning i wake up i look
at my phone and i realize that
okay it's not that i got six hours of
sleep but it's how much quality sleep
did i get
and you know i resonate so much with the
thing i resonate so much with the things
that you're saying about you know bring
technology and
what i i had an interesting episode with
a friend dan cyder from palo alto
and he has bipolar disorder he wrote
extensively about it
in in various tech magazines and one and
he worked he's working on a startup
where he's trying to help people combat
bipolar disorder by
using the webcam of the computer to
observe their facial expressions when
they're
working not on zoom when we're all
smiling and happy but in the mundane
day-to-day life
to give feedback and one thing that i've
realized you know over the past few
months here
is that there's just not enough people
that are working on these things not on
the on the you know
the illness side of it and not on the
wellness side of it which is why i think
what you're doing at joy ventures
is is really really awesome i totally
agree i'm glad you
you've realized that because i think
there's such a huge ocean of opportunity
to innovate
both for people who have more serious
suffering i also have a brother
who suffers from mental illness that's
another reason why you know it's also
close to my heart
um and that field you know of of um
mental illness you know desperately
needs innovation
and i think um you know all of the you
know artificial intelligence
and brain inspired computing and you
know every all of
all this great talent also that's you
know that's out there
um part of my mission has been in the
last 10 years whether at israel brain
technologies or
joy is to try to get people um who come
out with these you know
fabulous uh degrees from you know from
from very uh prestigious uh institutes
yeah so i really i really would love
you know more and more people to
discover this world
um of you know brain health brain uh
brain tech
what does it take what is it what does
it take for more entrepreneurs to get
excited about it because i i feel
and you know coming in now from both
from both 8200 and stanford
i'm getting a sense of understand why
why it's difficult for a lot of people
to start and
and i think it stems from this
perception that while you know
i may be excited about engineering and
data science and going into the field of
neuroscience i feel like i need to get a
phd in this in order to just begin to
understand
what's happening so that's not the case
it's really not the case
i think um you know first of all find a
neuroscientist
and partner with them you know i mean
there are plenty of neuroscientists out
there that would love
to use their you know knowledge and and
and
discoveries um in a way that you know
can help people
so um i think it's you know it's about
it's about
and it's and it doesn't only take place
in academia there's a lot of you know
great things that can happen but i
mentioned all these examples of ways
that you know
um ultimately it's understanding what
are the pains out there that people have
and just you know seeing how you can
even bring you know even just
kind of off-the-shelf technology in a
way right there's so many technology the
reason why we think that it's such a
great opportunity today
is because not only is science come so
far but technology has come so far
that you can do so much today with
available technology
just finding a way to make it accessible
you know to people who need it
uh and you know and there's so many
great things that you can do today
to like influence you know our state of
mind whether it's mixed reality
um you know using vrar um
and eeg is just one part of measuring
but there's so many ways that you can
influence you could there's so many ways
to stimulate our brain right
we can stimulate our cell any any of the
senses all of our senses end up
you know affecting how we feel right so
it's enough that for you to kind of do
some kind of vibration on my wrist
and you can help me calm down um you can
you know it doesn't have to be kind of
this deep tech
you know brain stimulation it can be
just you know hey it can even be just a
game
so we look at companies now that are
doing um really cool games to help
kids like deal with their emotions
amazing
train train them train kids to edit from
a very young age to be more empathetic
teach them empathy teach them kindness
you know so it's about
not only kind of feeling good but it's
also making us
kind of better people um incredible and
i think as long as you know
you're the kind of person that wants to
also
you know do something good um and you
and you know and you're really
passionate about technology there's
no reason why you can't mix both of
those up and it doesn't mean that doing
good
is you know is doesn't make money
there's huge markets for
you know for all of these types of
applications and it's only growing if
you take
my maybe my last comment will just be
that you know
these days with with the with the global
pandemic it's just
unbelievable the impact that it's had
on um on people's uh you know emotional
well-being
and general well-being i mean i think
there are a lot of people that until now
didn't realize or didn't kind of say oh
yeah i'm also stressed they kind of
always see
people around them and oh it's not my
problem right now
there isn't i think one person on the
planet um
that hasn't experienced you know sort of
the stress and anxiety
and depression associated with this
whole you know uncertainty
um around the you know pandemic whether
it's financial
you know financially driven because you
know someone is no longer working or
just not knowing what's going to happen
tomorrow
the social isolation and all the
loneliness that it's causing
people all of those things i mean
they're manifesting
themselves and just accelerating the
awareness and the need
um for solutions to help people cope
um you know with very high levels of
stress lack of sleep you know etc
so anything we can innovate anything we
can innovate to bring people
together through the screens to you know
to help people feel better to reduce
their stress
and it's not just meditation meditation
isn't for everyone you know
everyone's there's a lot of noise around
you know meditation through headspace
and calm and it's great right
but you know there's so many you know
not everybody likes it and
it's not the only way to kind of help
people
you know feel good so we're really
putting the call out there for really
smart
passionate you know techs and
entrepreneurs to
think about what you know what how can
technology
serve um you know humanity's uh you know
quest for well-being what kind of
products can we develop for consumers
um you know not not just not people who
are of course it's important to treat
people with
brain illness and but at the same time
there's so much opportunity to
to look at consumers you know the
day-to-day if it's our grandmothers if
it's our children
if it's our brothers and sisters you
know just help them
find ways to you know to feel good to
connect with each other
um and to create healthy habits i love
it so me read before you know before we
leave
two notes one if you know people have
this you know passion for wellness and
for
what i love what you said going about
solving the human quest for wellness and
well-being and and not just about
illnesses but you know i'm looking at my
own grandparents and how
there's so little solutions that connect
the younger generation to the older
generation
and it's it's unbelievable that i'm
watching you know i'm like
you know as a part of j ventures i get
to watch you know hundreds of different
startups come in yearly
so few of them are dealing with these
issues that are so prevalent and they're
and they're just growing i mean the
the gap is just increasing every day
that goes by so so definitely
they should reach out to joy ventures i
guess and and i think that you're
you're a perfect address to to give them
advice and to and to talk them through
their ideas and where we're headed
and and the second thing and the last
thing that i always love to do
is i'm gonna put you on the spot one
time during this interview and i need
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
or that anybody on your team would use
to describe yourself or rafi
or any of the entrepreneurs that you're
helping
uh so if it's describing me um
i think you know uh optimism
yeah is a really big part of who i am
um i really believe in the ability to
you know um to i really
see things see things you know you know
with that with that full
you know the half full cup i love it i
think
i think that when you when you work at
joy ventures you kind of bring optimism
to the table already just with a name
yeah yeah i really but it really is who
i am it's it's not just you know on
paper
um and for me also another big piece is
kind of
um connecting so i really love bringing
people together
um and i think that with you know with
innovation in startups that's also
certain it's
really super important i think when we
you know when we deal with innovation
um it's not just about one person it's
really about
um not only going out and kind of
talking to people and understanding
what are people's pains but also forming
teams and working together
and that's a big passion of mine is like
enabling innovation through by
connecting people and connecting you
know
um organizations and and people with
different um areas of expertise
um and uh i guess we have to like we
have to you know
because of this uh conversation we've
had i think we're gonna need to put the
word brain as the third one because you
know brain or brain tech
i think is going to be you know um is
going to be another good good keyword so
wonderful so optimism unity and
brain i love it i think it's a wonderful
combination miri i i can't wait to learn
more about what you guys do at joey
ventures
and and it resonates so much because you
know the reason i came here
to palo alto after the unit was to
understand what are some of the biggest
challenges that you know technology can
help solve
and the more i'm exposed to these ideas
the more passionate i get at them and
definitely i can see myself
taking part in this world the in in this
world that you're surrounded in
and and it just sounds fantastic miri
thank you for being so generous with
your time thank you for allowing me to
run over
because i enjoyed this interview so much
this is definitely longer than usual but
i just loved every
every minute of it so thank you very
much i enjoyed it too michael thank you
so much for uh for inviting me it's been
it's been a real joy
and good luck with uh with this program
it's a really
uh wonderful initiative i hope you enjoy
it too thank you thank you very very
much take care
take care all the best good help